tienen los eeuu que lanzarse a una
guerra comercial está la economía
norteamericana en peligro por el
gigantesco déficit comercial que
arrastra cada año está china compitiendo
de forma desleal como puede donald trump
proteger y defender a los eeuu
[Aplausos]
[Música]
al lado
en el sexto
belinda cuatro amigos una cosa son las
intenciones y otra muy distinta a los
resultados eso es precisamente lo que
pasa casi siempre con las políticas
proteccionistas pretenden una cosa pero
consiguen otra muy distinta
donald trump fue claro durante la
campaña electoral que le llevó a la casa
blanca y lo ha seguido siendo desde
el despacho oval las políticas
proteccionistas son una fantástica idea
igual 2 cam prisa del sur y aguanten de
aquí a aouate el bayern de que camps a
qué hotel trump anuncia la imposición de
aranceles a las importaciones de acero y
aluminio excluyendo a canadá y méxico
trump anuncian la imposición de
aranceles por casi 50 mil millones a las
importaciones chinas
trump amenaza a china con imponer
aranceles por otros 100 mil millones de
dólares de momento sólo están aprobados
los primeros los aranceles al acero y el
aluminio y se han excluido a muchos de
los países aliados
[Música]
y así fue
pero a tenor de las noticias si algo es
seguro es que trump tiene claro
clarísimo que una de sus grandes
prioridades es la lucha contra el
déficit exterior es decir reducir la
diferencia entre las importaciones y las
exportaciones una diferencia que supera
ojo los 500.000 millones de dólares cada
año
y ahí es donde entra siempre en juego el
recurso a los aranceles algo así como el
que vigente quiere comprar productos
extranjeros no importa ya verás como
aprenden a golpe de arancel
ahora bien seamos justos
[Música]
son muchos los que defienden que no es
que trump quiera meterse de lleno en una
guerra comercial sino que todas estas
amenazas del presidente de eeuu
especialmente contra china no son más
que un órdago una forma de obligar al
gobierno de xi jinping a sentarse en la
mesa y negociar
[Música]
y si puede ser que así sea pero como con
trampa nunca se sabe por si acaso y para
tener las cosas claras creo amigos que
tenemos que hacernos algunas preguntas
le convienen los eeuu a abrir fuego y
comenzar una guerra comercial sobre los
aranceles la mejor forma de ayudar a la
economía norteamericana está chila
infringiendo las normas está compitiendo
de forma desleal hay que castigar a
pekín veámoslo
es importante entender con chase
un mal plan para ningún problema
amigos os hago una pregunta qué pretende
un político cuando pone sobre la mesa
políticas proteccionistas no ganar votos
no es una respuesta válida sí sí ya lo
sé ganar votos es la prioridad número
uno de prácticamente todos los políticos
de este planeta pero por eso mismo no
hagamos trampas centrémonos en los
objetivos específicos de las políticas
proteccionistas pues creo que podemos
decir que los objetivos suelen ser
defender los empleos industriales
castigar una supuesta competencia
desleal generalmente por parte de países
más pobres e impulsar la economía local
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ahora bien esas son las intenciones pero
los resultados si eeuu desató una guerra
comercial con china va a lograr esos
objetivos pues amigos vayamos por partes
en primer lugar esto es lo que dice
donald trump bajo mi administración el
robo a la prosperidad americana
terminará vamos a defender nuestra
industria y crear unas reglas de juego
igualadas para el trabajador americano
donald trump wow menos mal que están los
políticos para defender al pueblo
norteamericano por cierto esta es la
misma excusa que utiliza para perseguir
la inmigración defender al trabajador
estadounidense solo hay un problema los
datos muestran una realidad muy
diferente
el mercado laboral de los eeuu vive su
mejor momento en casi dos décadas la
tasa de desempleo se sitúa alrededor del
4% y el número de vacantes sin cubrir
ojo crece como la espuma la máquina
económica norteamericana está empezando
a sufrir desabastecimiento del input más
importante de todos la mano de obra
tal cual como lo escucháis si no cambia
la política migratoria ni la economía se
viene abajo o claro se calcula que los
próximos diez años los eeuu tendrán más
de ocho millones de puestos de trabajo
sin cubrir
[Música]
aquí
esto es algo que ya está ocurriendo de
forma bastante intensa en el medio oeste
en estados como wisconsin donde hay
mucho empleo pero pocos trabajadores es
genial tener más puestos de trabajo que
nunca antes en wisconsin pero crea un
desafío solo necesitamos más gente
tricio brown directora de operaciones de
la agencia de desarrollo económico de
wisconsin en estos momentos la tasa de
paro en este estado en wisconsin está
por debajo del 3% y los nuevos empleos
no paran de surgir
por ejemplo el grupo taiwanés de
tecnología foxconn está invirtiendo más
de 10 mil millones de dólares en un
gigantesco campus para desarrollar y
producir nuevas pantallas para
smartphones tablets y televisiones dará
empleo a más de 13.000 personas
[Música]
la situación es tan curiosa que las
autoridades del estado se han visto
obligadas a poner en marcha una campaña
de publicidad por ejemplo en los trenes
de chicago y aquí mismo en youtube para
atraer trabajadores al estado pero no
sólo eso veréis es verdad que la
industria manufacturera de empleo y a
mucha menos gente que hace dos décadas
pero qué pensáis es culpa de la
competencia china
pues los datos nos dicen otra cosa no
sólo el empleo está en los niveles más
altos de la historia en la economía de
los eeuu sino que además la propia
producción industrial está también en
sus niveles más altos si la industria
contrata a menos personas pero eso no
quiere decir que produzcan menos lo que
ocurre es que las fábricas gracias a los
robots ya la tecnología son cada vez más
productivas
[Música]
por ejemplo echemos un vistazo a la
industria siderúrgica la que trampa ha
dicho está amenazada de muerte por la
competencia china y que además según sus
palabras supone todo un peligro para la
seguridad nacional bueno pues la
realidad es que eeuu produce el 70 por
ciento del acero que consume que apenas
el 3 por ciento es para uso militar
seguridad nacional
y que además china no está ni siquiera
entre los 10 primeros proveedores
si es verdad el empleo en la industria
siderúrgica se ha reducido a casi la
mitad en la última década pero amigos la
inmensa mayor parte de los puestos de
trabajo perdidos no se deben a china ni
al comercio internacional sino a la
tecnología y esto evidentemente una
guerra comercial no lo cambiaría pero
como veis tampoco es algo precisamente
malo hoy en los eeuu hay más empleo que
nunca y el déficit comercial bueno a
pesar de lo que diga tram no es tan malo
supone menos del 3% del pib y de hecho
se ha reducido bastante en los últimos
años
[Música]
además nos estamos olvidando de otros
detalles por ejemplo de las inversiones
eeuu tiene un saldo de inversiones netas
positivo es decir los extranjeros
invierten más en eeuu que los
norteamericanos en el extranjero algo
que evidentemente es muy bueno para el
futuro de la economía estadounidense en
2017 este saldo positivo superó los 250
mil millones de dólares
ahora bien pensáis que aquí acaba todo
pues estáis muy pero que muy equivocados
una guerra comercial no sabemos si
reduciría el déficit de exterior pero
tendría otras consecuencias no
precisamente deseables atentos
[Música]
las consecuencias
digámoslo alto y claro los mayores
afectados por una guerra comercial
contra las importaciones chinas serían
las propias empresas de los eeuu tal
cual como lo escucháis comprar inputs
más baratos en el extranjero reduce los
costes de producción de las industrias
locales y si además un país extranjero
en este caso china vende por debajo de
coste eso es como si pekín subvencionar
a las industrias norteamericanas y eso
la verdad no suena tan mal nos parece no
me creéis pues fijaos
eeuu no solo importada de china
productos para consumir también importa
muchos bienes intermedios y bienes de
capital como maquinaria por ejemplo de
hecho más de la mitad de todas las
importaciones desde china se
corresponden con este tipo de productos
y aquí la pregunta es que conseguirían
los aranceles pues precisamente dañar la
competitividad de las empresas
norteamericanas
[Música]
y encarecer el coste de producción de
bienes mucho más avanzados donde hoy la
industria de este país es líder lo que
supondría por ejemplo reducir sus
exportaciones al resto del mundo y
también la capacidad de consumo de los
propios estadounidenses elresultado
millones de empleos perdidos
por ejemplo el nuevo arancel sobre el
acero o el aluminio hará que la
producción en eeuu ojos de cosas que
utilizan acero y aluminio como los
coches o los aviones sea más cara y por
tanto menos competitivas
tendrán que fijarse nuevos aranceles a
los coches para compensar este mayor
coste de producción local
[Música]
esto amigos es lo que explica que cuando
en 2002 el entonces presidente george
bush impuso aranceles al acero importado
el saldo final fue de un total de
doscientos mil doscientos mil puestos de
trabajo destruidos vamos que el tiro le
salió por la culata
pero es que además hay otro detalle muy
importante cuando te fijas aranceles lo
normal es que la otra parte se defienda
no digo que esté bien pero ocurre si los
eeuu anuncian una serie de nuevos
aranceles por valor de 100 mil millones
china ya se ha preparado completamente y
no va a dudar en hacer un duro
contraataque gao feng portavoz del
ministerio de comercio de china
imaginemos por ejemplo el caso de boy
china es el mayor mercado para esta
compañía que en los próximos años se
entregará a este país cientos de nuevos
aviones pues bien una guerra comercial
podría dañar su posición competitiva a
largo plazo
china por ejemplo podría favorecer a
otras compañías como air bus y acelerar
el desarrollo de una industria local si
hoy por hoy parece difícil pero a largo
plazo las consecuencias podrían ser
enormes
[Música]
y no sólo eso sino además podría
recurrir también a otros medios menos
ortodoxos por ejemplo no olvidemos que
el gigante asiático es el mayor
propietario extranjero de deuda de los
eeuu sería bueno para washington que
china dejará de comprar deuda o que
incluso empezará a reducir sus títulos
como medida de presión
la respuesta claramente es no mucho
menos con el enorme déficit público que
está alimentando la actual
administración pero espérate un momento
porque hay algo lo que trae si tiene
razón
[Música]
esta china rompiendo las reglas
en una cosa del presidente de los eeuu
está en lo cierto
china no es precisamente un mercado
libre ni un país que juegue del todo
limpio y no solo se trata de que en
muchos casos tenga aranceles más altos o
favorezca a las empresas locales lo más
grave por ejemplo es el chantaje que
realiza las grandes multinacionales
si las empresas extranjeras quieren
vender libremente en china tienen que
aliarse con socios locales socios que
tienen acceso a la tecnología si esta
transferencia tecnológica supone en
cierto modo un problema porque estas
empresas chinas la utilizan para crecer
y competir
claro que las empresas tecnológicas
saben dónde se meten a cambio de acceder
al gran mercado chino tienen que ser
ellas las que decidan dónde producir
donde competir y qué negocios realizar
[Música]
eso sí esto no quiere decir que el
gobierno de eeuu no tenga que presionar
y negociar con china pero ojo desatar
una guerra comercial sería una solución
terriblemente mala mientras sólo sean
amenazas bueno pero mucho cuidado con
cruzar la línea roja así comienzan las
grandes crisis por fortuna salvo que
trump se empeñe parece que eso no va a
ocurrir
china denuncia a eeuu ante la
organización mundial del comercio y
anuncia más apertura comercial ahora
bien dicho todo esto un momento porque
queda una pregunta sobre la mesa por
contestar cómo puede eeuu reducir el
déficit comercial pues la mejor forma
para lograrlo es con apuestas con
políticas estructurales hacer ni más ni
menos lo que hicieron grandes potencias
exportadoras como alemania o suiza
favorecer el ahorro y por tanto la
inversión productiva a largo plazo
reducir el déficit público que al
sobrecalentar la economía impulsa el
consumo de importación y mejorar la
competitividad de las empresas locales
[Música]
por ejemplo reduciendo la burocracia
favoreciendo la atracción de talento si
la inmigración y bajando los impuestos
como hizo la última reforma fiscal del
partido republicano de la que os
hablamos en este vídeo esos son los
caminos una guerra comercial en cambio
es mala para todas las partes y en
cualquier caso un apunte el déficit
exterior no tiene por qué ser algo malo
todo depende de cuánto crezca la
economía para que se utilice o qué
ocurre con la inversión por ejemplo en
fin amigos así están las cosas pero
ahora turno para ti estás a favor de
poner aranceles a china déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo no olvides darle a
like y suscribirte a visual política si
aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]